欢迎各位说明天这期摆车圈说我是三刀。
今天这期节目咱们来聊一聊前不久小鹏发布的第二代VRA，
那也就是VRA2.0。
那么第二代的VRA物理世界大模型其实没有关注质价领域的人可能听不太懂。
就到底是个什么东西。
关注质价的朋友听起来可能觉得不明觉历，
大概也知道是个什么东西。
但是也很难说清楚，
就这个VRA它到底好在哪？
它背后是什么原理？
那么今天咱们聊一聊VRA把它展开来好好的讲一讲。
那么对于大家今后买车，
如果你是比较看重质价这一块，
那么小鹏这个所谓的二代VRA，
VRA2.0的车型它是不是应该作为优先的选择。
还有包括像什么华为的ADS啊，
还有其他的用什么摩曼塔的质价的，
还有那些芯片啊，
大家也搞不懂什么索尔芯片，
什么什么这个英伟达的芯片，
对大家也不知道到底好在哪？
就是很多的名词，
现在买车是就跟考物理一样的对吧，
就先把物理这门课先学会，
先研究透，
你将来还要研究化学，
因为你研究电池就是研究化学，
你数学也得好，
因为你最后还要算账算五连免息，
什么低利率对吧，
你语文也得好，
因为你这所有的什么配置的这些名词，
这稀稀古怪的加很多钱税的，
然后你这历史也得好对吧，
你不能再聊了，
再聊的话那地理也得好，
南方车旗，
北方车旗对吧，
就不同的地方的人的性格对吧，
有人讲这都已经是自动化了，
怎么还研究性格呢，
这有机会我们来聊一聊，
人家讲什么地缘政治，
地缘的造车工艺它也有一点区别，
因为我参观过很多的工厂，
就是从管理的规范程度上来讲，
不一定说是南方的管理好，
北方的管理就不好，
不一定，
因为北方你像宝马对吧，
宝马的工厂我去看过，
确实管理还是非常非常不错的，
但是这个是比较少的一种，
北方车旗的极其极其讲究细节和流程的，
主要还是看权重比，
就是国人说了算还是外资说了算，
因为这两年说实话，
外资的所谓的盒子当中的外方话语权，
是越来越弱了，
但也不代表说他们弱了，
就质量一定就差，
有机会好好聊，
人这个东西确实很有意思，
我觉得比什么所谓的制度，
比什么的这些都有意思，
那么今天就言归正传，
咱们这期节目就聊一聊，
就是VRA玩意它到底是个什么东西，
它到底厉害不厉害，
2.0的版本到底升级了什么，
有没有网上吹的那么的天花乱追，
还是说只是个概念，
还是真的有两把刷子，
那么首先我们解释一下VRA，
VRA以前节目里面也提到过，
叫Vision Language Action,。
视觉语言行动模型，
英文水平不用四级，
只要是初中过了，
基本上这几个单词应该都知道，
虽然我发音不太标准，
Vision Language Action,。
别献丑了，
一听就懂，
那么相当于是什么呢，
就是看到了什么，
然后用文字描述出来，
然后再根据文字去执行动作，
对吧,
那么之前大家经常会听到端道端，
端道端跟智能驾驶基本上都是连在一起的，
只要是宣传端道端道端，
基本上都会给你提到这个什么VRA，
那么现在大家买车，
你只要是带支架，
无非就是有激光力达的，
没有激光力达的两个版本，
那么没有激光力达的，
一般就是作为入门版，
低阶的残血版本，
那么有激光力达呢，
大家就称之为贵一点的，
叫做顶配版，
高阶版，
满血版，
那是不是有激光力达一定比，
没有激光力达更好呢，
我觉得倒不一定，
就是说这两个版本无非就是走两条路线嘛，
对吧,
一个是纯视觉路线，
一个是融合感知路线，
但是呢，
真的体验下来，
其实还是有激光力达的，
在某些复杂路况下，
极限的薄意向，
稍微要好一点，
但也有人问过这么一个问题，
就是激光力达所谓的多少线，
对吧,
现在都干到800多线了，
现在我用的那个就100多线，
什么128,192,。
什么这个陆陆续续的，
就是大家问那个问题，
就是在什么情况下，
这个激光力达在起作用，
它起的到底是什么作用，
就到今天为止，
就没有什么媒体能够详细的把它说明白，
就我举个例子，
比方讲，
这个好米玻璃呢，
大家都知道，
我们倒车的时候，
是能听到的，
DLE DLE DLE DLE DLE DLE。
对吧,
那这就是好米玻璃达，
那我知道啊，
摄像头我也知道啊，
什么时候摄像头启动，
你说屏幕上都能看到，
但是这个激光力达，
它在什么情况下用，
它能起到多大的作用，
对吧,
它什么时候接活了，
什么时候会是在休息，
这还真没人能也清楚，
这场家哪一天能不能解释一下，
我也很想知道啊，
那么基本上身边上就是这样，
没有激光力达的有激光力达的，
大家都也不知道，
激光力达到底起什么作用，
反正有钱就上，
没钱就卖没有激光的。
是吧？
还有一些车型是他本身就这个价位。
他都不带
你比方说十来万块钱的。
你说配个激光力达。
我说10万上下
现在其实十几万就已经有了。
10万上下的基本到现在。
还没有什么配激光力达的是吧？
那将来可能就越来越绝。
可能就七八万的也得给你配。
那么没有激光力达的走纯视觉。
有激光力达的走融合感知。
其实融合感知他本质上来讲。
也是基于视觉
他还是视觉
只不过带了激光力达多了一种保障。
对吧？
但是无论哪种方案。
有了现在更先进的这些硬件做基础。
所以这几家就是这些品牌。
现在都在往VRA这条路上一路狂飙。
那么有人讲说VRA刚刚你说了。
我知道是视觉语言行动模型。
但是还是有点抽象。
能不能再讲具体一点。
那么如果要讲具体一点。
我觉得就是大家应该了解一下。
现在小鹏不是说他是VRA2.0吗？
是第二代吗？
那我们就聊一聊就是现在在VRA2.0之前。
那么他之前是一代。
在一代之前还经历过什么？
那么其实一共是经历过三个阶段。
也就是在质价领域。
我们听到了质价这几个词。
其实在往前推
应该是能分成三个阶段。
那么第一个阶段
就是叫做模块化方案加高精地图。
什么意思呢？
就说白了
他是把感知预测规划控制。
他把它拆成一个一个的模块。
然后再靠人工编写规则。
去把它们串起来
就是我们之前讲的。
就是你写进去的
他能识别出来
你没有写进去的
他就跟傻子一样
什么都不知道
那个时候不叫质价。
那叫质账
那么车他是先靠传感器去识别。
像什么车道线
红绿灯
路牌
障碍物
然后再结合高精地图。
去判断说我现在在哪。
我应该往哪走
我下一步应该怎么做。
所以这套方案的问题在于。
就是刚刚我讲的
规则是要人提前先把它写死。
然后地图也得是高精的。
提前标好
然后他对于已知的这些场景。
他处理的还算可以。
但是一旦要是碰到没见过的。
没覆盖到的
或者说地图跟现实有一些偏差的。
那么系统就容易
就一年蒙蔽
不知道该怎么办了。
车停在那个地方
对吧？
前面有个车堵在那。
他也停在那
明明左边有两股车道都是空的。
他也他也不知道
那么这种其实说完了。
就是车他其实不是不会开。
车他只是遇到了没有之前背过的答案。
大家能理解吧？
就第一个阶段
所以早期的自动驾驶。
其实相当于没有泛化。
他采用的就是模块化。
那么高精度这样的一个地图。
它的依赖程度就非常高。
这也是后来为什么很多的这些车企。
他就想摆脱高精地图。
因为你高精地图不升级。
其实对他的这个质价想升级就非常难。
就是所有的车企都想摆脱。
说我要去高精地图。
对吧？
有前几年你要买车。
应该听到过这个词。
很多厂家都说
我不要高精地图
我要摆脱高精地图。
有些媒体认为是因为高精地图的授权的费用太贵。
其实这只是浅了
就车企付不出这个钱。
只要对吧？
你不是师徒大开口。
互相之间也是个博弈的过程。
地图公司跟车企之间是互相博弈的。
你用的多了
地图你说能有多少钱的成本。
对吧？
刚开始要加高一点。
用的多了
自然就便宜了
主要就是不想把主动权让出去。
这个是关键
那么这是第一阶段。
到了第二阶段
就摆脱高精地图了。
开始从人工写规则变成了。
就是让这个模型
去通过海量的驾驶数据去学习。
那么也就是大家经常听到的。
叫什么端道端
对吧？
或者说是偏端道端的一个数据驱动方案。
那么大家可以怎么理解。
第一阶段相当于是。
老师把这个答案写在黑板上。
让这个车给背下来。
到了第二阶段
就是大量的
抽象一点想
就是大量的人类司机怎么开车。
然后把这个数据喂给他。
就是什么叫Clips。
对吧？
把这个东西喂给他。
让他去学
让他去看
让他去输入
让他去了解输入跟输入之间的一个关系。
就是画面是什么？
好
然后我后面应该怎么操作。
就是看到这个画面了。
我的方向盘应该打多少方向。
我油门应该踩多大的油门。
我的刹车应该踩多大的刹车的力度。
就是这样子
就是最傻瓜式的看图学化。
看图不叫学化了
叫看图学操作
那么这个阶段
它比第一阶段稍微的先进了一点点。
因为什么呢？
因为它减少了人工规则的这样的一个叫堆器。
或者说人工规则的预先的写入。
它其实是就通过这个训练。
然后迭代它的相关效率。
就本质上来讲是一种硬设学习。
那么也就是说
现在这种操作
就是第二阶段的操作。
它更多的就像那个猴子。
在模仿人类的动作。
他也不知道这个动作是什么意思。
反正就是你怎么做我也怎么做。
对吧？
他就不知道那个瓶盖子怎么开。
他看到人是这样子。
手握在上面
往右旋转
因为他跟我们一样。
手往上一操作都是跟人类差不多。
他也旋转
他发现就开开来了。
他至少学会这个
他下次再扔给他一个罐头。
他就知道怎么开了。
那就是瓶子
就不是罐头瓶子怎么开。
但是他不是真正的理解了。
说这是因为上面有罗口。
有罗口有罗文
这个瓶盖子是往左旋。
历时针是把它锁紧。
顺时针是把它解开。
他根本就不懂
什么叫罗文
什么叫旋紧
什么叫领开
反正就知道这么个动作。
换句话讲
就是这个训练场景。
见过的场景
他会越就是他训练的。
越多
他就越熟悉
对吧？
但是没有训练过的。
这种常委的一些场景。
他照样是不会的
就是他没有创造
跟推理的过程
那么这是第二阶段。
第二阶段
还有个很致命的问题。
也是我曾经在讲端道端的时候提到过。
就是他中间所有的推倒过程是没有的。
或者说他有
但是你不知道
他也没办法给你解释。
就是他看到了这个推出了那个结果。
他看到了这个推出了那样的一个动作。
但是如果他看到了这个。
他结果做出了一个错误的动作。
你很难准确的说出来。
他为什么会做出这个错误的动作。
就是他很难追溯
你只看到结果不对。
但是他是在哪个层面不对。
你很难去追溯
是感知层面错了
还是理解层面错了。
还是规划层面错了。
不知道
所以因此
这个车子
他会开
但是他不会解释
他没有开口
就像人一样
他没有跟你一个交流的过程。
他就像个什么呢？
他就像这个小镇桌梯家。
小镇桌梯家刷了很多的题。
你给他一道题
他一看这个题目刷到过的。
他立刻就能把答案给填上来。
他甚至于答案都没有读完。
他只要看这个答案开头的那一半句话。
他可能答案一共三三句话。
对吧？
他看到第一句
他就能锁定
就这个答案就是百分之百是对的。
因为他刷到过
对吧？
那么如果说
你让他讲这个题目背后的逻辑。
他考的是什么？
是抽象思维
还是什么立体思维。
还是什么逻辑思维什么的。
他说不清楚
但这个题他会
他给的答案是对的。
那么对于支架这种。
相对来讲
对安全的要求比较高的系统来讲。
这个就比较的麻烦。
为什么呢？
因为就是你不光要他会做。
你还要知道他为什么这么做。
如果出了问题
怎么查怎么改
怎么验证
对不对
因为这涉及到这个人的生命安全的事情。
你包括出了很多的支架的事故。
你最后让他厂家去。
给出相关的一些
这个叫什么说明
他也说不了
最后反正就说出来在什么最后0.01秒。
然后支架解除了人工接管了。
那这个你说责任判断给谁呢？
你也讲不清楚
确实也讲不清楚
所以接下来就到了第三个阶段。
也就是我们今天讲的。
还不是今天讲的VRA的2.0。
是我们今天提到的VRA的一代。
第三阶段是VRA的第一代。
那么这个第一代
就是视觉语言行动模型。
它就叫VRA
那么这一代跟我们前面讲的。
这两个阶段
最大的区别是什么呢？
不是说他能开口解释了。
不是的
是他终于能够看得更加的清楚。
那么他开始试着去理解。
然后再去行动
那么以前就是VRA之前的系统。
很多的时候是看到画面直接输出。
看到画面直接输出。
就像一根线把它串起来。
输入接输出
那这个节奏是特别的快。
是吧？
输出的这个节奏特别快。
但是他到底理解多少不好讲。
VRA本质上来讲。
就相当于是一次
相当于重新修正
或者说是从底层上来讲。
他就是一种重新的架构。
他把视觉信息
语言知识
还有行动决策
放到了一个更加统一的框架里面。
就他不仅仅想知道前面有车。
有灯 有行人
他还要进一步的去理解。
就这个场景里面谁更危险。
哪个目标更加的关键。
你比如说这个行人。
他是站在那个地方准备横穿马路呢？
还是说他只是在那边等人。
他只在玩手机
穿马路的概率比较低。
所以他在这个路口。
或者说是复杂路况下。
真正该优先处理的矛盾到底是什么？
他会有一个理解
那么VRA的核心就是把视觉感知。
语意理解
语言推理
还有什么轨迹动作输出。
他把它更紧密的会连在一起。
所以我们简单总结一下。
就是说
质价
到我们听到这个词的时候。
当时我们觉得他像个质账。
因为在第一阶段
是把规则先人工的把它写死。
那么车子就像查字典一样。
像翻说明书一样
就是看到什么的 会的。
那我就真的会了
但是我词典里面
我词库里面
我提库里面没有的。
他就跟呆子一样的。
他就愣在那个地方。
不知道该怎么做
那么第二阶段
就是通过数据去模仿。
就像看别人开车
别人怎么开 我怎么开。
我也不知道这里面为什么要这么开。
反正他说他这么做。
我也就这么做了
就照着学
学的多了
很多常见的题目他也做得还不错。
但是就像小镇作题家。
没有真正理解这个题背后的一些用意。
只是刷过了
只是贴上了正确答案而已。
那么题目稍微改过弯。
稍微的题目给你延展一下。
需要加两条辅助线。
你就没见过这样的说法。
所以你就容易翻车。
那么第三个阶段
就是我们刚刚讲的叫一代的VRA。
那么这个时候开始往理解提议的方向去走了。
不仅仅是单纯记住这个题。
答案是怎么写
那么他要去看到这个画面。
然后往左打一把方向。
看到那个路口
我应该踩一脚刹车。
同时他要尝试去回答。
另一个关键的问题就是。
我刚刚的那一把方向。
我的这一脚刹车
我为什么要这么做。
就是他会把环境里面的视觉信息。
和这种高层的语意的知识。
还有行为的逻辑
他把它结合起来
然后去深深动作或者是轨迹。
所以理论上来讲
他就可以对于一些。
没见过的陌生场景。
常委场景
复杂的那些交付场景。
他会比前面的
我们刚讲两个阶段。
他会更加的有潜力一点。
那么现在很多的VRA的论文。
我也看过一点
非常的枯燥
但是咬着牙看
这怎么办
因为要做这样的一个节目。
我看VRA的论文里面。
其实都在强调一件事情。
就是想让这个车
不只是有反应
还要会推理
会解释
其实现在大家发现。
就AI更像人了
给你的讲话
对吧？
那些文字的AI
像我用chatgbt。
jaminer
gorg
还有国内的这些dpc。
什么的
你跟他聊得越多
你就越感觉他像个人一样的。
是不是
他会更奸继
就是在车上来讲
就会更接近人类的驾驶逻辑。
人类处理这种复杂的博弈场景的。
那种方式跟方法
都想让车变成个老司机。
是不是
所以我们现在聊了半天。
还没聊到VRA的2.0。
我们只是在说前面几个阶段。
就是在VRA之前。
那个初级的第一阶段和第二阶段。
感知
他不等于理解
只是看到了
不能看懂
那么动作
他不等于推理
他只会条件反射
硬射
他不会去思考
那么在VRA产生之后。
视觉加语言
加动作
深度融合
他就具备语意理解了。
他就具备常识推理。
泛化的能力
他能看懂路牌
能理解场景
能推理因果
能够去应对一些未知的障碍。
所以他基本上
实现了这个初级的。
所谓的看懂
听懂
还能作对
这就是第一代
好
那我们接下来就要讲重点了。
就是小鹏的第二代的VRA。
他有什么不同
那么如果说
一代的VRA解决的是。
车开始试着去理解这个世界。
那么这个二代的VRA。
解决的就是
车看懂之后
能不能像人一样
把前因后果给它串起来。
然后再决定下一步该怎么做。
有人说
哎
这个刚刚那个一代也没什么区别吗？
你继续往下听
区别还是很大的
这个差别看上去
只是从能理解到更会理解。
但是本质上
它不是同一个层次了。
为什么呢？
我举个例子
这个一代呢？
就像是一个
还算是比较聪明的实习生。
到这个公司里面了。
对吧？
你把这个场景给他做一遍。
叫他这个怎么操作。
他能够大致看明白。
他也能模仿
做个什么八九不离十的。
这个跟老员工一样的动作。
他知道前面是个路口。
旁边有行人
左边有车会插进来。
他这个时候要干嘛呢？
要减速
应该观察
应该必让
就是他都知道
他比前两代强的地方在哪。
就是他不再只会被提。
而是开始会独提
但是问题在于什么？
就他很多时候
还是停留在看懂这个层面。
我们刚讲第一阶段。
第二阶段
其实只是你输入一个规则。
他照着执行
但是VRA的这个刚开始的初级阶段。
他只是看懂
照着执行
但是接下来会发生什么？
他的理解还不是很深。
他不会预判
那么二代的VRA想做的是什么？
他要从看懂眼前到看穿局势。
从叫看懂到洞察
这说的有点夸张了。
到洞察
他不只是识别
是不是一个路口
是不是有一个行人。
是不是有一个施工的追捅。
他还要去判断
为什么会出现这些东西。
这个行人
他是准备过马路
还是说站着等人
这台电动车是在正常的靠边。
还是下一秒会突然横切。
前方这台车会减速。
还是因为拥堵
这个追捅为什么会出现在这。
是不是在修路
他要去预测前面的各种可能性。
他要去预测风险
我们经常讲的叫防御性驾驶。
我们正常人如果看到路上。
老远看到有两三个追捅。
我第一反应就是前面肯定是修路了。
路会变得越来越窄。
车到了这个路口
肯定是要汇入
那么既然要汇入
我的右侧会不会有风险。
结果后说进一看
果不其然
有个车子冰陷进来了。
这个时候你要不做任何的提前的预防的动作。
很有可能
你说我就是开直线。
我有没变到
你是没变到
可是你没让速
或者说你没加速
你就从那车头前面穿出去。
你跟他如果并行
那旁边的车会认为说你什么意思。
你是不想让我并到你这个线里面来。
我这边已经没有路了。
有些人他就觉得你会让。
但是你没让
结果两个人就喷傻了。
所以这就是一切老司机提前预判的结果。
那么甚至于比方到一个路口。
红绿灯看不见了
或者说红绿灯坏掉了。
下雪天覆盖了
那么交警抬手这个动作。
交警抬手这个动作。
他是让你走
还是让你停
那你说车他是知道还是不知道呢？
是不是就像我们到了个警区。
我们到了警区之后。
很多那些饭店的老板。
那个手使劲的挥
使劲的挥
就想让你进去吃饭。
那你说这个车子
他是判断前面站着的那个老板。
是个交警
还是说判断这个老板。
是想忽悠我去他们店里面。
宰我一顿
他如果说他判断这个。
这个老板是个交警。
那这个车子是不是就。
没有往前开
就直接跟着他进了他们家停车场了。
你车停好之后你吃还是不吃呢？
所以说白了就是一代。
一代的这个VLA。
他跟相是什么呢？
是把场景
他把它翻译成动作。
二代呢？
他是试着把这个场景啊？
翻译成意图
就是对意图是什么？
他试着理解这个意图。
所以我们再带来一个比较典型的场景来讲。
前方如果是个没有明确保护的一个路口。
右侧有个大车
他遮挡了路线
那么路边站着一个人。
站着一个人
就典型的可能会出现这个鬼探头的这个情况。
是不是
那么这个人的身后。
如果是个大人身后还有个小孩。
大人带着个小孩
那么这个场景正常的一代的VLA。
他大概率是什么？
我的右侧是个大货车。
大货车的右侧是大人带小孩。
有减速啊？
这个时候减速肯定不肯定不能超车嘛？
对不对
减速
因为你要如果在这个路口超车的话。
大人万一带着小孩。
一个鬼探头
那这一撞就是两个。
但是呢？
这种他不是说聪明。
这种其实更像是一种经验性的反应。
因为他是识别到了这个危险的这样一个构行。
所以他先保守一点。
我另一边慢一点
我另一边不超车
但是二代的VLA呢？
他如果做的更成熟。
他不单单是知道这里面有危险。
而且他会进一步的推理。
他推理什么呢？
就是个大人啊？
他站位靠前
头朝路口
小孩这个身体有前请的趋势。
小孩有往前请的趋势。
而且两个人之间
没有明显的牵手的约束。
大人没有牵着孩子的手。
那么下一秒
小孩突然冲出来的概率就非常的高。
那我讲到这
我估计很多人就开始猜到我要说什么了。
前段时间是不是网上有个视频啊？
有一个这个节目里。
我就不提牌子的这个牌子了。
大家都知道的啊？
就看过的视频的人都知道的。
那么他的这个视频的录像下方显示。
是开着自驾的
结果一个小孩突然之间横穿马路。
实际上小孩横穿马路这个动作。
距离从视频来看
距离这个车的
这个车头的位置已经非常非常近了。
哪怕就是个老司机。
你让他临时反应正常的话。
这个速度当时应该是30多公里每小时。
30来公里的话
也不算快
就很慢的一个速度了。
但你想一下子杀停也很难。
就人的正常的反应速度。
关键是他跟不上
所以那小孩就被撞了。
但是后来我们看到后续的报道。
这孩子没事
孩子没事
因为车主看到有截图。
说孩子没什么大碍啊？
这也是不幸中的万幸。
但是很多人就要讨论这个问题了。
你制驾不是想撞都难吗？
你制驾不是撞不到人吗？
你不是只要放心制驾。
你就睡觉就可以了吗？
现在没人敢这么宣传。
他只是个辅助驾驶。
本质上来讲
但是我也觉得很奇怪。
就那个视频我看的很奇怪。
因为我平时在用智能驾驶的时候。
如果路边站着行人。
如果这是一个斑马线。
他是会减速的
或者说他不会用非常快的速度。
去通过的
但是为什么会出现这种情况。
你撞了孩子之后
那个车就还是停下来了。
我们还是讲刚刚讲的VRA的2代。
VRA的2.0就是第二代的他的动作。
他遇到这种情况
右边有大货车遮挡视线。
然后有个大人带孩子。
大人没有牵孩子的手。
他的动作不只是减速。
他不只是减速
而是他会很早就开始把油门往回收了。
更坚决一点的
就是你会发现
他已经开始被杀了。
就像老司机脚上
已经是他在刹车踏板上面。
已经开始给了那么一点点的刹车力道了。
就是随时随地准备一脚。
躲下去 紧急刹停。
对不对
所以他是通过遮挡区。
他是把整套的风险。
他这个预案先摆出来。
他做一个防备的姿态。
你表面看这个车不是一样吗？
跟一代是一样的吗？
他只是慢了一点
但是你要知道这背后思路是完全不一样的。
一个只是看见了风险在应对。
一个是他会预判这个风险要发生。
他先提前站个位
脚上刹车先提前站个位。
那么再讲一个更复杂的城市场景。
就比方讲红绿灯
被雪覆盖了
或者像南京一样
每次一下完雨
很多的红绿灯就坏掉。
我也不知道为什么？
南京只要一下雨
很多路口红绿灯就坏掉。
那么这个时候红绿灯路口坏掉的话。
没有交警
那你就是观察路口就正常通过。
如果是有交警指挥。
那么对于一代的VRA来说。
他也许能够识别出交警的动作。
就让你往前走
还是让你停车
他也能结合周围的车流量。
别的车都在走
那我就不要傻傻的停在这了。
我也跟着走
他会做出一个相对合理的选择。
有
一代的VRA很多的车企。
也能做到这一点
但是这个过程他更像是什么？
他像是把多个这种得到的信号。
把它拼起来
就哪个信号更加的明显。
他就觉得说更有把握。
他就听谁的
但是这个二代的VRA。
他追求的是对于这个交通秩序。
优先级
他有一个本身的理解。
他不是说我看到一个人在挥手。
这个人是个交警
然后我就知道
我就可以走了
不是的
他是会去判断
现场人工
或者说交警的指挥的权重。
是不是高于这个已经坏掉的信号灯。
或者是被遮挡的信号灯。
还是说要高于地图的预期。
还是说要高于静态的交通规则。
他不是说只是识别这个动作。
他去理解
他理解这个动作背后。
整个交通系统里面。
我是处于什么样的角色。
那么我面前就得到这些信号。
他们是权重比是多少。
所以他会给出的动作。
不像一代的VRA。
他靠去蒙
给他蒙对了
交警的权重比更高。
他给他蒙对了
而现在是更接近于人类老司机。
他只要看一眼
他就知道了
在这个场景里面
你不要多想
这个场景盯着交警就可以了。
交警让你走
你就走
让你停 你就停
他知道该听谁的
他会有一个预判断。
那么再往下说
就是比方讲同样的施工。
绕形的场景
如果是一代的VRA。
他可能会表现得像一个。
很谨慎的一个好学生。
他看到追捅了
看到这个路面
开始临时改到了
看到地面的
这个叫引导线
或者导航线
他就有点对不上了。
他就开始小心翼翼的。
速度非常慢的往前。
一点一点的蹭
对吧？
那么这个场景
是在他的理解的边界内。
他也是能够过的
但是二代的VRA。
如果
就是说如果将来成熟了。
现在其实刚开始做。
他还是需要慢慢的优化。
如果真的做得很成熟了。
他会表现的
就像一个非常有经验的老司机。
你再去看他过这种修路的。
就比方说四车道变三车道。
三车道变两车道
最后变成一股车道。
你看他是怎么操作的。
他虽然说
这个地面上他能识别出来。
还是有那么四股车道的线。
但是他会发现
这明显已经开始放了很多的追捅。
开始往左侧去引导我们。
就是路是变得越来越窄。
越来越窄了
是吧？
他也会有导流牌
也会有线速牌
让你速度越来越慢。
那么虽然说
这个路口右边还能走。
就右边的两股车道还能走。
但是前车的轨迹
还有这个互蓝的开口。
还有这个施工人员。
有的时候在挥旗子。
让车辆全部往左
就明确会告诉他
正确的路线应该是往左借道。
就是四车道变三车道。
三车道变两车道变一车道。
最终你能通过这个路口。
只有左边的那股车道。
所以这个时候他就不是避障了。
他的逻辑就是
他要去还原现场这个临时的秩序。
他要现在去判断
马上去判断
我应该往哪个道去走。
老司机也是这样的。
老司机也是这样子的。
如果我是四车道在最右边那股车道。
我不可能傻傻的一直在右边慢慢的往前蹭。
我提前就要开始往左三。
左二
最后并到最左边那股车道。
但往往有的时候最左边那股是最慢的。
但是你想过
你肯定是从最左边那股。
因为你只有左一的口子是开的。
是吧？
所以你这么理解
一个是在复杂的场景里面。
勉强不犯错
他是能主动找到真正的通行的逻辑。
所以讲了那么多
讲了三个案例
就一代跟二代
最大的区别是什么？
不是说识别的精度。
从原来的85% 90%。
现在提升到95%。
也不是说感觉好像刹车更加的柔了。
转向更加的顺了
这些都是结果
你要知道真正合性的差别是在于。
一代主要还是在做场景道动作的一个硬设。
二代已经开始去理解场景道意图的过程了。
然后再做动作的一个推演。
所以一代它更像是什么呢？
是经验
经验丰富了
然后驱动的就会更加的顺畅一些。
那么二代就更像是。
前面我们也提到过叫世界模型驱动。
大世界的一个模型驱动。
那么一代相当于就是我见过类似的。
所以我知道应该大概怎么办。
那么二代相当于就是我既是没见过一模一样的。
我也能根据现在的环境发生的这件事情。
我会推测将来会发生什么？
接下来我应该怎么做。
所以你看背后的逻辑其实也不难理解。
因为真实道路最难的是什么？
从来不是说你给我一道什么体义。
我之前做过了
我怎么样到标准答案来操作。
它没有标准答案
这个路是完全开放的。
是不是这个体也是半开放的。
所以红绿灯
那车现在都能认识。
车道线车都能识别。
那问题是如果没有线了。
如果没有红绿灯了。
如果不按套路来
就跟你去博弈的那些车辆。
它都是不按照交通规则来。
车跟人
人跟车
车跟车之间
你有个博弈
有个试探的过程
你怎么操作
所以在中国开车就这一点不太好。
对吧？
你要想能够拼到旁边那个车道。
那很多人就是不打转向灯。
因为你打转向灯你永远插不进队。
我希望早日不是这样子的。
早日就是在家摇下车窗。
跟四季师傅说一声。
帮忙让我插个队
是吧？
就是你要遇到这种场景。
那可能好说话的
它也就让你过了
所以中国车企太了解。
咱们中国的道路灯通环境了。
所以现在你说要往自动驾驶方面上去发展。
你怎么去自动驾驶。
这么复杂的一种博弈环境。
所以想要把制驾往这个。
更先进的
更聪明的方向去推。
你不可能永远给它写题。
然后答题
不可能你扩提库是没有用的。
你提库扩的再大
你也挡不住现实世界。
每个人都在出新的题。
每个老司机都在那边去出新题。
对不对
所以一代的VRA。
是让车第一次开始摆脱死金一倍。
而这个二代的VRA。
它是继续往前走
就是让它能够有一种。
举一反三的能力
有一种能够动查的。
能够预先防御的
能够去理解意图的能力。
真的不容易
真的
我觉得车企往这方向去研究。
真的是花了老鼻子的钱了。
所以为什么现在车企都要去做机器人。
我一会要讲
它这种举一反三的能力。
这种预判的能力
这不就是机器人应该具备的吗？
所以车就不就跟机器人一样吗？
所以我也要提到非常可惜的一个品牌。
就是极月
极月的广告语就是什么汽车机器人。
很多人就不理解
什么汽车机器人
你车就车机器人就机器人。
实际上百度早就已经洞穿了。
这个局面了
就是车造车的企业将来一定是造机器人的。
因为它这个能力完全可以无缝对接。
可以移植过去
去做居身智能
对不对
我们继续往下讲
那么当然了
大家也可以去把它理解成。
就是一代是让车从条件反射精华道初步理解。
那么二代是让车从初步理解精华道连续推理。
所以一代它解决的是。
不要像一个什么机器人。
又说到机器人了
就不要那么机械的去开车。
那么二代的解决的是什么？
你能不能越来越像老司机一样的。
在路口你能够提前几秒钟。
你就能知道将来要发生什么？
你脑子里面的过一遍。
能够具备这种防御型的驾驶。
不要再出现任何的意外。
在不出现意外
不出现事故的情况下。
能不能高效的去解决驾驶的效率问题。
就是能够让你如果为了安全。
为了谨慎开得那么慢。
对吧？
兜兜缩缩的
有忧郁的不敢过
很多人也觉得自驾的这种。
体验不是很好
那既能够防御型驾驶。
又能够保证效率
这就是最牛白的职能驾驶。
也是大家最想要的。
所以说到底谁能够更加接近。
真正的比老司机还老司机的支驾。
就不在乎说你吹的有多悬乎。
而是我上车
我只要去试一段最复杂。
最多博弈的场景
那我就能知道
这个车我值不值得付钱。
你吹的再很没有用。
所以你要让我去评价说。
刀哥二代的VLA怎么样。
我觉得怎么吹都没有用。
你就跟销售讲
你找一个晚高峰
5点多中6点钟的时间。
你说你带我去
去最堵的那条路
我们南京就是什么沉中干道。
沉溪干道
你走一圈
不要多你跑个三五公里。
最堵你地图打开来。
找那个最红的
就红的发紫的那种路段。
那就完全堵了也不行。
就一定要是又堵
然后又是挥入路口。
最好还是个大转盘。
然后还要在那个路口。
只有两个车道的地方调个头。
原地调个头
你让他的那个地方给你来个博弈。
你就能知道这个车。
他到底是不是他当时吹的那么狠。
你看他的预判的能力。
场景的意图的理解能力。
你双手打开嘛？
反正销售肯定你跟你讲。
他说我们支架多好。
ok
你只要这段路全程高效的。
安全的带我送回来。
没有任何的碰擦
我就马上下单
对吧？
如果说中间出问题了。
你不要算我的
我开个录音
就是你车的问题
就是你广告宣传的吹过了。
嘿嘿嘿
对吧？
有的销售为了卖车。
他也敢承诺
可以没问题
没问题
你看
你说的啊？
只要全程
你给他寄个屎嘛？
你说我正常老司机开。
你看地图上判断
就是我一个来回的话是。
原来说25分钟
这样子我再给你放宽5分钟吧？
30分钟之内
我开到这个路口
吊个头回到CS店。
他能够做到这一点。
我马上下单
哎
你看他读一把
这多开心啊？
订单前
银行卡
这个账户的余额发给他看。
嘿嘿嘿
销售肯定特别开心。
你说的啊？
你说的
我带你走一圈
好
那么走一圈
这个关键是
小鹏哪些车有二代的vr a 呢？
这个你要搞清楚啊？
就听到刚刚上面这一段。
你是不是觉得说好像这东西很神。
好像很厉害
对吧啊进化了啊？
离自动驾驶越来越近了。
但我想告诉你就是。
小鹏的vr a 的二代。
相当于比以前厉害了一点。
或者说他具备了一点。
这种可以解释啊？
有一点这种推理的能力了。
但是距离自动驾驶的这个路啊？
还是很长远的
我是觉得这里面
其实问题还是有的。
而且这问题下不少。
我们一个一个的讲啊？
首先我们先知道
小鹏哪些车是有二代的vr a。
你本管好不好
肯定比以前的要好嘛？
对吧？
那么根据小鹏官方披露的信息呢？
第二代的vr a 除了推送给。
这些有三颗图灵芯片的叫outra 版。
他也会推给啊？
两颗图灵芯片的
就是outra se。
就跟手机一样还有se。
他也会推送给
单颗图灵芯片的
就是max 版本。
只不过他推送的这个版本和推送的节奏啊？
他不太一样
你比如说小鹏G6啊？
官方就有解释
他说outra 版outra se的版本。
会在今年的4月份。
开启第二代的vr a 的全量推送。
那么max 版呢？
会在今年的下半年。
推送真流后的版本。
那么有人讲说什么叫真流。
真流其实你可以理解为。
就是烟割版嘛？
残血版对吧？
就是把它里面的一些核心的基础提炼出来。
你上个什么高速啊？
上一个这个
城市的这个高快路段。
就是快速路啊？
相对来讲
比以前聪明一点
但是你要想在城市的复杂路况下博弈。
有所提升
我估计是比较难的。
真流版就是烟割或者残血。
然后单图灵的max 版。
双图灵的outra se。
和三图灵的outra。
他也不是同一个推送的版本。
所以你要记住啊？
他们之间的能力
也是层层往上去递进的。
那么至于说更老的一些平台。
还有那些就是没有用图灵芯片的。
那些车型
那么我看到说
官方有可能也会给一些。
你比方说all in X的这个叫做真流版。
那其实真流版也是残血嘛？
就是能力给你一些提升。
但是以后我个人觉得。
小鹏这边的重心啊？
还是会放在他们家的图灵芯片的。
这个版本的升级上。
你本管是单图灵双图灵还是三图灵。
那将来一定重点就是这个。
一定重点是这个
因为现在才二代嘛？
你麻后面可能很快就是三代就出来了。
你在后面四代
你陆陆续续的
你原来没有用图灵芯片的。
他就可能
就所谓的给你一个真流。
也就是适当的深点级安慰安慰了。
就以后肯定还是用自家芯片的车。
主力去升级
对吧？
这个大家也能理解。
那么目前来讲的话。
三颗图灵芯片的包含。
比方说P7 Ultra。
G7 Ultra。
X9 Ultra。
G6 Ultra等等。
那么两颗图灵芯片的包含。
像X9 Ultra SE。
G7 Ultra SE。
G6 Ultra SE等等。
那么这个两颗跟三颗之间。
主要就是少了一个。
未来做仓的融合能力。
其他的其实都是一样的。
那么一颗图灵芯片的就包含。
像P7 Max
G7 Max
G6 Max等等。
所以我个人觉得
更多的可能大家还是会选。
这个Ultra SE。
如果说预算完全充足。
那就直接去买这个Ultra了。
那么至于说这个Max版本。
它主要就是有刚刚说的。
就是高快路段
高速还是城市的一些快速路。
它没有像
我们讲就三颗图灵。
两颗图灵推送的版本那样。
有全场景的能力
或者说在应对一些极端的。
博弈的这种场景里面。
复杂的场景里面
提升就不会那么太大了。
所以大家也能理解。
因为它现在是用它的质价的能力。
去做它的溢价的差异。
以后你可能看到其他配置都差不多。
就是一个质价不一样。
结果中间就差个1万 2万 3万。
你就不知道该怎么选了。
我觉得今天我解释的已经很清楚了。
说白了你在城市的多车。
然后各种施工
各种复杂的
一上路上就堵车
然后天天都要在城区用质价的。
你有这种强需求
你说我每天上班下班。
我就是不想扶扶上班。
当时法规是要求你扶的。
你象征性的还是要去扶一下。
但是开车你别玩手机。
你还是要盯着路上去看。
就是说你想让它给你减轻驾驶的压力。
你说我只要出门
我就用支架
你就不要想了
你要么就是双图零。
要么就是三图零
你直接上凹权
或者是凹权SE
你说我没有那么多的支架需求。
我无非就是跑高速的时候。
开一下支架
或者是在这种快速路上面。
就云速能够跑个六七十码。
八十
六七十公里米小时。
八十公里米小时
我就开一下
平时如果是真的路况复杂。
我就自己开
那你买个什么单颗图零芯片的。
也没什么问题
你就买个MAX版也没什么问题。
这个我说的已经很清楚了。
对吧？
那么我记得小鹏
刚开始去亮相三颗图零芯片的时候。
我还不太建议大家去入。
有人讲说当时是先上了两颗。
有一颗是后面在给你按。
就是厂家当时也觉得这个有点过剩了。
就支架的能力有点过剩了。
酸力有点过剩了
那么现在来看的话。
就当这个二代的VRA的推送一出来。
我就觉得你现在当下如果再选小鹏的车。
你只要口袋里的子弹充足。
预算充足三颗图零肯定是首选。
这个酸力还是要的。
那么三颗图零芯片其实分工也比较的明确。
两颗芯片是组成一个计算单元。
是专门负责自动驾驶。
所有的感知融合规划决策。
都是在这个里面去完成。
那么还有一个芯片是独立出来的。
是专门负责
就大家都知道现在是什么？
仓架异体
就智能坐舱
这一颗芯片是负责智能坐舱。
那么也就是你的语音助手。
车载娱乐
导航地图
手势控制这些
都是由这一颗芯片来做的。
那么也有人讲这么一句话。
说三颗图零芯片
它分工明确
也没有互相干扰
但实际上
市面上其他的都是有干扰的。
也不是这么回事
这个我要稍微解释一下。
市面上你像什么8155芯片。
什么8295芯片。
然后再加上NVIDIA的Orin X。
它芯片也是分开的。
也是坐舱归坐舱
但是后来出了一些芯片。
你比如说现在会出现。
仓架异体
然后直接用
就是索尔U
大家记得吗？
现在很多车是用索尔U。
然后告诉你仓架异体。
也就是说
它确确实实是坐舱跟智架。
现在是共用一个芯片的算理了。
还有那个叫
那个是叫高通
875大家还记得。
有一些车
它就是只用这一颗芯片。
同时去处理它的坐舱。
以及它的智架
那么在这种情况下。
你如果跟小朋友
这个三颗图灵芯片去比。
那是不能比的
因为这个是
这二八斤是完全2加1。
就是2加1分工明确的。
那为什么要这么做。
因为我们知道就是。
自动驾驶或者叫智能驾驶辅助。
它跟娱乐系统
就刚刚讲的
它有一些智驾的这种框架里面。
它是共享资源的
那么共享资源
它并不是说它的算力处理不了。
工程师也不傻
它也测算过
它是能处理的
但是它容易会导致。
中间它系统内部
会有一些资源冲突。
那么一旦要是有资源冲突。
内存被打断
它会导致我们也会经常看到的那种。
叫幽灵刹车
就是你会发现前面什么也没有。
没有人
没有障碍物
突然一脚刹车
大家遇到过这样吗？
这就是我们刚刚讲的。
叫系统内部资源冲突。
内存被打断
会导致这样的一个。
莫名其妙的一种情况。
虽然不多见
但是可能会遇到
那么小鹏这个三星片的方案。
它其实是用最物理的。
最直接的
简单粗暴的方式
是解决这样的一个问题。
开车归开车
听歌归听歌
两个系统
两个大脑
它不互相干扰
那么这是典型的一个叫做。
垂直整合的一个思维。
最底层的硬件
到上层的软件
每一个环节
我要自己掌控
我要让它极致的优化。
虽然我花了很多的钱。
我花了很多的精力。
但是这个做法的好处。
就是它会把这个性能。
会炸干到极致
那么小鹏的这三块图灵芯片。
并年的总算力是2，250TOPS。
那么作为对比的话。
隔壁的英伟达NVIDIA的旗舰平台。
也就是我们刚刚讲的JAPSOR。
SOR的算力是2，000TOPS。
那感觉差别不大
对吧？
也就差了个2，5。
但是这意味着什么呢？
就是小鹏其实是自研方案。
放在自己的量产车上。
他的纸面参数比芯片的巨头。
NVIDIA会稍微高一点。
然后再配一个216GB的。
非常大的一个内存。
那么这就导致
它可以把一个
就是相当于300亿参数的大语言模型。
完整的塞到这个车里面。
然后实现本地化运行。
那么以前的车
它只能跑个几十亿参数的模型。
这个我相信最近大家听到什么龙虾。
龙虾或者是本地部署。
什么你应该能多少知道一点。
如果这个你完全不知道。
可能你就需要去补补课了。
就是或者这么讲
就比方说我们去国外。
你说你要联网
才能用那个翻译软件。
那你很多时候你可能用的就不顺畅。
但如果是他有本地的翻译。
或者说地图
你如果把地图下载下来。
你不用网络
你就不会出现说没有网的时候。
你跑不了地图
没有网在地图本地它也能运行。
大概是这么个意思。
那么以前的车
它只能跑个几十亿参数的模型。
如果遇到复杂的一些情况。
你比如说看不清楚前方的事故是什么情况。
看不清楚障碍物
那么它需要把数据传到云端计算一下。
再传回来
也许很快
也许可能就有那么个半秒。
但你要知道半秒一秒。
你如果在高速的情况下。
你车子已经就冲出去。
你就是杀你也杀不住。
也杀出去可能几十米了。
所以你想一想
人肉眼判断前面的障碍物。
然后再加上几十米的沙亭距离。
这是不是深和死的距离。
所以小鹏的
就这样的一个模型。
它部署在本地
那么它的思考过程。
能够把它做到50到100毫秒。
50到100毫秒内就能完成。
它甚至这个速度都比人类的这种。
通过眼睛看到
然后脚上去才去动作。
还要再快一点
所以这就是叫垂直整合。
然后死磕硬件
就不停地让硬件去叠带。
然后让软件去升级。
它会带来非常大的一个优势。
这个不衰不黑
我一直都讲华为的支架。
跟小朋友支架
这两个都是第一梯队。
今天相当于就是展开来讲。
它为什么是第一梯队。
那么NVIDIA那边。
英伟达是怎么操作的呢？
我们就知道很多的车企。
它可能自己没有什么支架。
或者是支架发布的比较晚。
那基本上都是跟着英伟达走。
都是用英伟达的这个芯片。
那么英伟达NVIDIA。
老黄就是穿皮衣的老男人。
老黄
老黄他就说了
他说我们这个叫做NVIDIA。
GF-SOAR
SOAR这样一个模型。
那么这个模型怎么去操作呢？
就是它不强调单一硬件的性能。
它是提了一个更宏大的概念。
叫做物理AI
其实这个物理AI。
我相信你只要稍微关注一下。
很多地方都在讲
那这个物理AI什么意思呢？
它的理解就是自动驾驶。
是物理AI时代的杀手机应用。
它是非常看好车辆的。
只能驾驶这一块
那么NVIDIA的策略。
它不是说我要去造一台完美的车。
我
我干嘛我提供一个开放的AI的厨房。
就是他们这样的一个叫GF-SOAR的。
这样一个平台
那么这个平台呢？
就是提供一个中央厨房。
里面有最好的炉子。
有最锋利的刀具
有最新鲜的食材
那么这个厨房你来不来。
车企
比亚迪吉利日产
来我给你挥手
来来谈一谈谈一谈。
那么到了我的厨房里面。
或者说你把我的厨房。
我或者这么讲
我给你们加
厨房改造一下
那么你想烧什么样的菜。
你是做川菜
多放点辣椒花椒
还是要做越菜
讲究火候
新鲜
这个口感都不一样。
你可以根据自己的爱好来。
所以它这个方案更适合是全球化去铺。
它可以根据每一个车企。
在不同的国家
他们的路况
法规
还有它的品牌的驾驶风格。
去调制
他们自己的这种驾驶系统。
自动驾驶系统
那么这样一来的话。
相当于就是说
各家车企拿过来之后。
就像给AI的大厨一个指令。
今天做菜我要安全跟舒适是第一位的。
我不去追求它的速度。
那么这个车的价值风格。
就会变得跟柔和一些。
跟保守一点
那么相反我要激进一点。
你也可以跟它讲
对吧？
所以它是一种水平扩展的一个平台思维。
那么这个跟小鹏的区别。
我觉得它的优势在哪呢？
首先第一点
它会让很多的车企。
它明明执轮驾驶
没有花很多钱去研发。
但是用上它这一套系统。
它就可以得到目前。
可以说这个地球上算是比较先进的一套支架技术。
那么第二一个
就是各家车企
它会去拿这个所谓的中央厨房。
去定制让自己的一些相关的规则。
定制这个车辆的一个驾驶的风格。
所以你想像欧洲呀日本啊？
这些地方它的这个车辆相关的上路的法规。
是非常严格的
而且有些地方也会有很独特的一些。
要求法规的要求
那么就可以在这样一个方案里面去定制它。
所以这就出现两个非常不同的一个路径了。
小鹏相当于是个好的工匠。
但是它要自己去打造一把完美的宝剑。
从链钢开始
然后去断打去开刃。
就每个细节全部都是小鹏自己来做。
那么虽然说哎行程必还了吗？
也打造出了一个风力无比的剑了吗？
哎他自己用的也很顺手吗？
但是别人他不用剑。
或者说别人他用不了这把剑。
对吧用了这把剑可能就没割到别人。
先割到自己了
所以就只有小鹏自己用的最顺手。
他没办法复制
没办法复制
你只能是指望小鹏卖的越来越多。
成为地球上第一大的车企。
你否则的话这个技术再好。
你只能自己用
那么尔维迪亚呢？
尔维迪亚像是一个军火商。
他是打造一个可以生产各种武器的兵工厂。
我前面那个厨房的比喻。
我感觉没有像兵工厂比喻更形象一些。
他就是把图纸
生产线方案全部开放给你。
然后你自己去造适合你自己的枪和炮。
所以这样一场硬件的战争。
我觉得他没有绝对的谁赢谁输。
他其实是一个
我感觉就更像是一个哲学的辩论。
你会发现你研究车企的这种质价的方案。
到最后就研究人性。
他是哲学辩论
是把一辆车本身打磨的越来越聪明。
形成一个接近于老司机一样的。
很聪明的像人一样的一个完美的个体。
还是说
你要创造一个生态。
让世界上所有的车都融入进去。
都接入到智能的网络里面。
就不是一辆车卖的好。
是大家一起卖的好。
一龙俱龙对吧？
一损俱损
全球的车企如果封田也在用。
分市宝马也在用
大众也在用
然后国内的一些支架度的不好的车企都在用。
你觉得这些车企的在路上跑的量。
跟小鹏一辆车企跑的量。
谁的量更大
这里面也讲究训练的。
是不是谁训练的速度越快。
迭代的速度越快
谁就越成熟
这个市场相当于也是个零合博弈。
但是这样听下来
你的感觉是不是有点像苹果的封闭系统。
跟安卓的开放式的系统。
是不是有种重感觉了。
是吧？
所以你看各行各业。
特别是这种科技性行业。
你做到最后就是这两种方案。
就是苹果的方案跟安卓的方案。
开放的方案和封闭的方案。
你说谁能赢
谁会刮掉
那现在苹果该卖不也在卖吗？
安卓该用不也在用吗？
都在用
各有各的市场
好
那我们前面聊的是硬件方面的不同思路。
那么下面我们讲一讲软件方面。
那么在VLA这个大的框架下面。
其实不同的公司对于智能的理解。
它也会有一些分化。
那么这里面就出现了两种非常有意思的。
叫做AI人格
一种叫做预言家
另外一种叫自行者。
就听起来有点像狼人沙。
你往后听就更像狼人沙了。
我跟你说
那么我们先说预言家。
预言家的代表车企。
就是理想汽车
虽然有些人可能对理想汽车颇有威慈。
但是也有很多的人。
还是很喜欢理想这个牌子的。
就喜欢它的设计语言。
产品定义
这个我们先泡到一边不谈。
我们只讲自驾
或者说它的智能这一块。
理想汽车
它有一套系统
叫做My VLAOE。
那么这套系统
它比较厉害的地方在于什么呢？
它不仅能够看清楚现在。
它还能生成未来
有人讲说三刀
你怎么吹着神乎七神的。
你别急
我给你解释一下
就是传统的所谓的自动驾驶。
或者智能驾驶
它是看到然后反应对不对。
是这样一个模式
我看到一个行人
我计算一下它的速度和方向。
然后我决定是刹车还是绕行。
但是理想的这套系统。
它是在看到那个行人的一瞬间。
它这个大牢里面
或者说它的计算机的模型里面。
它会立刻生成好几个未来三秒钟的。
3D动画短片
那么第一个短片里面。
这个行人停下来是看手机的。
第二个短片里面
这个行人他是突然横穿马路了。
那么第三个短片里面。
他可能被旁边的一辆自行车。
或者是摩托车吓倒了。
他往后退了一步
那么这套系统
我刚说的只是三个短片。
很有可能他推演出了十几种可能性。
并且他给每一种可能性分配一个概率。
然后选择一个无论在哪种未来里面。
都是安全的驾驶策略。
所以你要如果开过。
最近的新款的理想的车型。
你会发现
它在开支架的时候。
它旁边会有一个小窗口。
那个窗口里面就会出现。
就是各种的那种数据在来回的洞。
它为什么在来回的洞。
就是在生成这样的一个。
未来的所谓的这个短片。
或者说未来的一个判断。
它在不停的筛选方案。
不停的筛选方案
那么这就跟下围棋是一个道理。
对吧？
围棋的高手
他在落子之前
他脑子里面就在想。
后面的十几步
甚至几十步
所有的变化
极尽所有的可能
他的这些变化
我这个子到底下在哪个地方。
他的胜率更高
所以为什么？
像下象棋的旁边会有一个解说。
解说的屏幕上面就会一直有胜率。
这个子一落下去之后。
胜率就会变
这个子一落下去
讲到这我再给你讲一讲。
我最近玩王者荣耀。
我现在王者荣耀
我是单排辅助上分。
单排
我现在已经40多颗星。
快50颗星了
那么其实我自己打。
我的能力我是知道的。
上了王者
我以前的能力
基本上就是10颗星。
20颗星
还得要有大神带着我。
为什么现在我单排能上到50。
我觉得50也很轻松了。
我只是没时间
有时间我感觉我还能再往上走。
是因为我用了AI。
有人说有何三刀
你打个游戏还用AI。
你每次打完了
你还跟AI聊一聊天。
不是的
大家知道有一个软件叫王者营地吗？
你在王者营地里面。
你打开
然后在游戏界面
你不就能看到你的每一局的胜负吗？
对吧？
你的得分是多少
在得分里面
你点开来之后
你注意看
点开来之后
这里有个叫副盘
你把副盘点开来之后。
第一行
第二行
第二行就是AI分析。
你点一个AI分析。
它就会把你整场的比赛几分几秒。
你做的比较好
几分几秒
你可以做的更好
或者说你失误
然后你整局的判断。
到底哪些地方是能提升的。
以及你这场比赛
跟你近期所有的比赛。
哪些地方你的风格有变化。
它甚至能知道你的风格有变化。
然后你如何去出庄。
如何去在那个时间点。
是保设手
还是要突进开团什么的。
讲得清清楚楚
我就非常明显地感知到。
就是通过我反复的去看。
因为我现在已经是赢得多。
输得少了
我就把我输的那几局反复的去看。
我就对我的整个的提升。
就是我知道每一分每一秒。
我就要干什么了
就对于我整个意识的判断。
我作为一个辅助
我应该不停的去探视野。
我以前都不知道探视野。
到底什么叫探视野。
那不就是跟到射手来回转吗？
不是这个概念
对吧？
什么时候先手开团。
什么时候去去去去后手。
去去保射手还是怎样。
我应该出什么装备。
哇就感觉整个就
玩了十来年的玩着荣耀。
但是就在这一刻
通过AI的反复的去分析判断。
每一我甚至知道每一分每一秒。
我们家的胜率大概是多少。
我看到AI的时候跟我的判断。
其实是差不多的
不管是从经济上
还是从我们现在整体团战的胜率上。
前两天遇到一个对局更夸张的是什么？
一上来卡卡卡中路送五个人头。
然后紧跟着上路一直在骂中路。
骂到最后上路
卡卡卡又送了三四个人头。
就已经就局面是0-9了。
然后在后面打打打打。
最后就是可能十几个人头。
比两三个人头
那基本上就是输的局。
但是就是这种情况。
我跟射手来回换线。
来回去推塔
一直推到他们家的高地。
然后大家一看好像局面上有点有点有点意思了。
再去偷个龙
偷完龙之后再去一波团。
一波团先供他们家的后面的后排。
后排断了之后前排根本没什么伤害。
对不对
一波团灭
再去推推到高地一波带走。
所以这种就是纯利风都能赢。
为什么呀？
就是因为用了这种AI。
就是我对于局势的判断。
我觉得射的时候没有放弃。
他是主ADC是强输出行的。
然后我呢？
我觉得也有胜的概率。
那几个人不是不会玩。
是心态崩掉了
怎么让他们的心态能够再拉回来。
你说要想一直跟那家团团团是团不赢的。
所以就只能把它推到高地。
把塔先推掉
推完之后再回过头来。
想想办法是不是能找机会。
在我们家的塔下
再去搞一波团灭
然后再抢个龙
然后推高地
所以我觉得真的很有意思。
虽然说我刚刚讲的是游戏。
有些人可能听不太懂。
但是男同胞应该没有不玩玩的荣耀的。
玩鲁
应该大部分人都会。
你要能听得懂这一段。
我就知道你应该是能理解。
就是现在的车辆通过AI。
通过这种算力
通过这种算法
这种预判
它不是在反应
它是不停的在判断。
它在毫秒之间
已经是能看到那种潜在的危险。
并且它提前做好了规避的动作。
那么这种深沉式的世界模型的技术背后。
它其实是用的叫做3D高丝建设。
一个比较前沿的图形学和AI的技术。
它构建的它不是一个平面的了看图。
而是一个可以被推演。
可以被想象的一个三维世界。
那么当然了
这样做也是有缺点的。
就是它的代价就是算力的消耗极大。
现在天天都说什么投肯。
投肯是吧？
其实大概就这么个意思。
算力消耗大
然后各方面你想
硬件要求也高
对吧？
它的成本也高
那么理想现在赌的是什么？
就是理想赌的是对未来的一个判断。
他觉得这种趋势是靠谱的。
他觉得将来用这么大的一个算力。
但是我带来了一点点的安全荣誉。
他觉得是值得的
所以理想汽车走的就是预言家的路线。
它是向外看
它试图去穷进世界上所有的可能性。
但是也有人觉得这是不靠谱的。
因为这个世界上的可能性。
你根本就不可能穷进。
是绝对不可能穷进的。
永远有你未知的风险存在在那个地方。
那么我们现在就讲到第二个。
叫做自行者
自行者自行
就是自我反省
那么这个代表的公司它不是车企。
它是一家做自动驾驶的公司。
叫做deep root。
这名字可能不熟悉。
但是我要再讲一个叫圆容启行。
我估计很多一些车迷。
或者是汽车行业的人一听就说。
圆容启行都知道了。
圆容启行
圆容启行在GTC大会上面。
就展示过一个VRA的模型。
那么这个模型它是装了一个400亿参数的。
旁人大物
那么这个模型很有意思的就是它的架构。
它这个架构呢？
它相当于就是这个系统在开车的时候。
可以一星三用
你可以想象一下
这套系统有三种人格。
一个是扮演司机
一个是扮演分析师。
一个是扮演批评家。
是不是又有点像狼人沙。
像狼人沙
前面是预言家
那个是自行者
现在自行者里面还要再分成司机。
分析师和批评家
那么这个分开来讲。
先说司机
司机呢？
司机大家都知道
司机你只负责专心开车就可以了。
你只负责处理眼前的路况。
做出转向 刹车 加速。
就这么几件事
我们知道一辆车能不能上路开。
就老司机就查三样东西。
方向盘
转向也没有问题
刹车也没有问题
加速也没有问题
能刹得住
能加油门 能转向。
那这车就能开
你本管它几百万公里。
你本管它几十年的车灵。
所以司机
这就是它的本质工作。
你干好这三件事
那么分析师呢？
分析师就是在后台。
什么都不干
默默的观察
哎呀小眼睛就在那边盯着。
就盯着这个司机的一举一动。
然后不断的去分析。
分析司机跟周围环境的互动。
如果遇到了一个关键的。
复杂的或者是危险的场景的时候。
你比如说一次紧急的避让。
或者是一次
就是处理的不太完美的一个变道。
这个分析师就拿个小笔笔。
就在那边给他寄下来。
嗯
这个表现不是很好。
他要分析因果
刚刚为什么会撞上了。
为什么会撞上了
你给我解释一下
啊？
因为你没有看到他。
还是说
因为你这个预判错了那个那个行人。
或者是老太太
或者是电动自行车车主的意图。
他拿个小笔笔给你寄下来。
啊？
你每一次不完美
每一次的或者是错不得处理。
他都给你寄下来
那么第三个是批评家。
他有人讲批评家跟这个。
分析师不是一个道理吗？
哎
你听啊？
这个批评家
批评家
他不关心你具体的操作。
他只负责停驾司机开的好不好。
他从三个维度来打分。
安全
舒适
还有就是你的整个操作是否流畅和自然。
你比如说
还是刚刚那个一个变道。
变道好
你这个变道虽然很安全。
但是对不起
你的动作太生硬了。
你让后排的乘客不舒服。
啊？
这个要扣分
要扣分
然后你过这个路口。
哎
你这个路口是过去了。
可是你过这个路口太犹豫了。
你就像个新手
你不够果断
扣分
所以你看就一层比一层要求更高。
对吧？
我们刚刚讲的是吗？
分析师分析师只是在多多车。
这种复杂路况下博弈。
然后呢？
他有些场景你做的不好。
或者判断错误
预判错误
意图错误
他给你记下来
批评家就要求你要像个老司机。
你要更安全
更舒适
每个操作
你要照顾到每个人。
啊？
这个不行
这个只能给你六分啊？
那个还可以给你八分啊？
这个太差了
我只能给你五分
我的天哪
兄弟啊？
这不就又回到我刚刚讲打王者荣耀吗？
对不对
每次赢的时候
那都是十几分
是吧？
甚至于什么顶级辅助。
也拿过很多次
顶级辅助
那几乎就是满分了。
十五分的十五点几了。
但是每次输的时候。
那我输的分数其实也不低啊？
但低的时候就五点几六点几。
那正常
又输了
可能也是八点几九点几。
你本职工都做好了。
但这个分数很重要。
你往往看到这个分数。
你就知道你很多地方。
你的成伤不够
对吧？
你可能这个
这个叫什么伤害不够。
你每次成伤的死亡的这个概率太高了。
所以
这个车他也是一个道理。
三个人格同时工作。
形成一个避缓
司机在开车
分析师在找问题
批评家在打分
然后那些标记出来的。
不好的失败的坏的案例。
和有价值的案例
他就被系统自动优先提取出来。
然后进入到下一轮的模型训练。
他不就形成了一种。
自我进化的机制了吗？
听起来是不是有点毛骨悚然啊？
他自我进化了
我的妈呀？
所以他就不需要
成千上万的人工标注员。
然后从海量的视频数据里面。
大海捞针一样的
去找那些有用的训练的素材。
他现在自己就是
最严格的训练导师。
自己给自己找茶
自己给自己去改作业。
我的妈呀？
就我们家孩子如果能做到这一点。
自己给自己去买个辅导书。
然后自己去训练
那他就进化了
所以这个模式
最终带来的结果是非常惊人的。
传统车企的数据
迭代周期可能是一周甚至更长。
但是你看袁绒启行。
他的这一套
如果一旦要是落实的话。
他的迭代周期可以缩短到。
只有12个小时
不是缩短12个小时啊？
是缩短到只有12个小时。
就是12个小时之后就迭代了。
就你一觉睡醒迭代了。
你一觉睡醒迭代了。
每天迭代两次
什么概念啊？
这就意味着他们的ASG的学习和进步的速度。
是别的车企
4倍甚至是14倍。
他可能今天犯了一个错。
当然我告诉你
明天他就不会再犯这个错了。
所以你看理想
这个预言家是向外看。
他要理解预测这个复杂的世界。
而这个袁绒启行的方案。
他是自行者
他是向内看
他是试图反思跟完善自己的人格。
他们用的都是VLA。
都是VLA
他们都是在用语言和逻辑去解释这个世界。
但是一个是预测未来。
一个是反思过去
是不是这么个道理。
所以你说哪个更接近我们人类顶尖司机的加持知觉呢？
其实我觉得可能两者都有。
你想一想
如果啊？
如果是个老司机
我们听有里面肯定有这种。
就是开了十几年车。
几乎没有出过任何的事故。
甚至连小碰小擦都很少。
对吧？
那你有人讲就是我就是我。
评论区告诉我你是不是你啊？
一个优秀的司机
他是既要眼关六路。
预判风险
那也要每一次开车之后。
他去默默的覆盘
今天自己拿你开的不好。
做的不好
所以就这两种ai的人格的冲突和融合。
很有可能就是通往真正通用人工智能的一条必经之路。
那我们前面调了那么多。
大家是不是听到这越来越兴奋了啊？
觉得我们离自动驾驶。
是不是越来越近了。
但是大家想过一个问题没有。
技术在厉害
算力在强
数据在多
最终还是要解决一个最根本的问题。
就是我们
我们作为人类
作为一个探机生物。
你敢不敢用它
你敢不敢把生命交到这个小铁盒子里面。
让这个机器它来开。
你完全不用管
你敢吗？
你毕竟在大马路上。
你不是坐在高铁里面啊？
那高铁他下面还有轨道吗？
卡死在轨道里面对吧？
你在大马路上不一样。
你是开放式的
你没有固定的路线啊？
你虽然有导航路线。
但是路的你左车道右车道你随便开。
所以你又没有发现。
就当这个开车的环境。
无法去改变的时候。
就是所有的车企的思路就是。
通往自动驾驶的最核心的环节是什么？
你环境没法改变
那我现在所做的每一个。
它的智能体
能不能把它的操作给我解释一下。
就是用可解释性
带来对于信任的一个重够。
因为你最终的结果是什么？
你要让人类去相信自动驾驶。
要建立信任
那怎么建立信任
他就跟哑巴一样
他每个动作你问他。
他都不给你回答
现在自动驾驶相当于。
不能叫自动驾驶
智能驾驶辅助
他现在开始解释了。
他告诉你我是怎么判断的。
我的意图是什么？
过去几年自动驾驶的事故。
每一次出事
网上落得沸沸扬扬的。
为什么落得沸沸扬扬的。
因为没有任何的解释。
这个动作到底是什么事。
为什么到最后的0.01秒。
最后的0.5秒
0.1秒
你解除了
为什么让人物接管。
你为什么甩锅
出了事之后
车企站出来说
哎呀？
给这个媒体
给这个监管机构
说我给你看
然后看什么呢？
看一堆复杂的神经网络全中图。
给你看几百页的日制。
还有代码
谁能看得懂
没人能看得懂
但他能给到你的
就是这么多东西
他说根据我们的模型分析。
当时的系统决策
在概率上来讲
就是最有解
这个解释听得懂吗？
那普通人听不懂
监管也很头疼
这个就好比什么？
你说医生做完手术了。
这个病人给他手术做刮了。
然后家属问他说怎么回事。
这个病人明明好到难的。
给你推进去
你说最后人没推出来呢？
对不对
他说对不起
我们尽力了
我们是严格按照
这个你看不懂的一本医学操作手册进行的。
然后这个操作手术上面。
我们是
这个根据判断
他的成功率是最高的。
但是成功率最高也不是100%。
对吧？
所以这个节哀顺便。
你说这个解释你能接受吗？
你肯定不能接受
你会觉得
但要么就是医术不经。
要么就是推卸责任。
是不是
那么现在二代的VRA的出现。
就解决了这个问题。
什么意思呢？
就是说
如果监管机构去问他。
所以你刚刚这台手术到底出了什么问题。
为什么这个人活端端的活活的进去。
结果就挂了
他能把所有的这些过程。
全部给你去复盘一遍。
他每一次下刀
每一个切割的过程。
他能告诉你这个原理在哪。
意图在哪
那么最终
为什么没救回来
就是连个普通老百姓一听就能听命卖。
不用给你转那么多的医学词汇。
那么换到车上来讲的话。
就是你的车在那个路口。
为什么要减速
你的依据是什么？
工程师你不用给我摔那个权重笔。
也不用给我摔出一个什么什么数据。
我也看不懂
对吧？
你可以直接
你就讲
你就车子里面
当时就播放了这段语音。
语音里面是这么说的。
由于我观察到前方有临时路排。
但是信号灯被鸡血覆盖无法识别。
因此
我是根据前方穿制服的交警。
他的手势引导
我是慢速通过的
所以我就给你解释了。
为什么在路口
我要减速
是因为我看不到信号灯。
但是有交警跟我挥手。
所以我慢速通过了。
所以他有了这么一段解释。
有时候想说
车子里面会解释吗？
你去看看小鹏的演示的视频。
当时小鹏的演示视频就是这一段。
就是这一段
他就给你突然车子里面出现的声音。
给你解释了一下
这是一个清晰有逻辑。
符合人类常识的解释。
那么监管者一听就明白了。
或者说老百姓一听就明白了。
你当时这个动作
你的判断是这么想的。
你有预判
那么你的思路也很合理。
而且你的操作也很很安全。
甚至于他可以再进一步的给你进行讨论。
如果再往下发展
他甚至于可以告诉你。
就当时如果没有交警站在那边指挥。
红绿灯他也不显示了。
他会怎么做
系统甚至就是VRA的。
甚至三代四代
他会直接告诉你答案。
没有人指挥
红绿灯我也无法确认。
我无法确认我的路权。
我能否安全通过
那我的策略就是停车等待。
直到确认安全
或者是请求人类接管。
所以你看
当这个机器开始可以用语言。
来解释自己的决策。
他的这个决策逻辑的时候。
他就不是一个冰冷的。
不可预知的那个他。
就是什么规矩生物。
那个他他就不能叫生物了。
就是个规矩
这个他是宝盖头的。
但是现在他就变成了一个。
能够沟通的
可以理解的那个他。
那这个他
单人旁的女子旁的。
你自己看了对吧？
他相当于是你的伙伴。
讲的呢？
可能大家觉得说有点太悬夫了。
但是我告诉你
如果按照这种方向发展下去。
一点不悬
一点不悬夫
这个就是将来的一个。
确确定定的大趋势。
那么可解释性
我觉得是今年二零二六年。
智能驾驶的一个
一个一个非常明显的。
变革的方向
那么他带来的连锁的反应是什么呢？
从监管层面上来讲。
大家都知道
现在监管机构也是批准。
这个L3级的自动驾驶开始上路了。
那么他的审批要求里面。
大家注意看
因为那个条款很枯燥。
如果你感兴趣
你可以去看一下
其中有一条
他要求就是决策的可解释性和透明度。
那么这样呢？
就相当于是倒逼所有的车企。
你必须往VRA这个方向去走。
那么第二一个
我觉得影响最大的就是保险公司。
现在人都在讲说
保险公司的这个保费太贵了。
续保
如果二手车的评估才二十来万。
续保的保费能干到六七千块钱。
是不是
你看我的阿维塔就是。
其实我阿维塔
我就只能卖到十几万了。
现在
但是我的保费都要是。
四五千
那么保险公司
我看到有这个资深人士当时透露讲。
说他们现在开发一个新的车显产品。
他未来能够提供清晰的决策日治。
能够解释自己行为的车辆。
那么保费会大幅的降低。
而那些还在使用
就类似于一个黑盒黑箱操作的这种系统。
他解释不了他的过程。
那么保费他会高的离谱。
为什么呢？
因为能解释的话
责任就清晰了
除了事故
一看日治
是系统判断失误
还是硬件故障
一目了然
对吧？
那其实说白了
就是要甩一部分的锅给厂家。
找厂家去追责
因为你说我开智能驾驶的。
所以这就是涉及到将来的智能驾驶。
怎么去评判
很多的车企不是说开制价出了事故。
我们兜底吗？
那你兜底你怎么兜呢？
你的制价现在能说话吗？
你的制价透明吗？
能解释吗？
如果你到了VLA的二代三代。
已经能解释了
已经能够看到他的日治。
清清楚楚的每一次的判断。
他的意图是什么？
那保险公司也很开心啊？
保险公司说
你车企说兜底吗？
你就得兜外
最终还是钱的事情。
保险公司少赔钱
车企多赔钱
那你妈肯定是不掏钱的。
对吧？
你左边有车企兜底。
右边有保险公司兜底。
所以对于保险公司来讲。
就降低了最大的不确定性。
所以这是一个巨大的经济杠杆。
其实对于我们车主来讲。
是一个利好的消息。
那么最最重要的就第三点。
就是公众的信任
你说所有的人都在搞自动驾驶。
你现在到路上去采访。
有几个人真的敢去用。
你别说自动驾驶
就现在的辅助驾驶有几个人敢用啊？
那么这个信任是非常重要的。
就当你坐在一辆有自动驾驶的车里面。
这个车突然靠边停车了。
诶
他为什么靠边停车啊？
什么情况啊？
这不是前面的路都是空着的吗？
然后车内的云
这个时候开始想起。
说
道哥
你不用担心
因为我发现
右后方快速接近了一辆救护车。
我们是在让路
啊呀这么有素质
不错不错不错
对吧？
那么如果这只是一次。
那么两次三次四次五次。
甚至每一天
当然就有点啰嗦了。
这车子里面不停的在跟你讲话。
这怎么解决我不知道啊？
就是说他反正他的每次动作。
他能够解答你的疑惑。
当你有疑惑的时候。
他能跟你说出来
他为什么这么做
你就会发现
这种透明
是任何的参数
任何的技术都换不来的。
这是一种信任的构建过程。
你要知道
这个比我们前面说的任何一点。
都重要
所以我们今天聊那么多。
从我们讲硬件的战争。
到算法的灵魂
再到数据的洪流
再到最后落到这个信任的重建。
那么这一切其实都指向一个结论。
就是2026年
确实是自动驾驶
一个巨大的拐点
那么这个转折
他不仅仅是车变得更聪明。
而是车
他终于学会了一种。
用我们能够听得懂的方式。
去解释
他为什么会变聪明。
所以说关于这个什么？
所谓的物理AI这个概念。
我们也不能简单的把这个什么？
VLA的架构理解成。
就是用于自动驾驶。
你想一想
一个能够理解视觉。
能够运用语言
甚至能够做出行动的AI的。
这样的一套这个系统。
你把它从车子里面拿出来。
你把它放到一个机器人里面。
那他不是能做更多的事情吗？
所以小鹏为什么？
同时在做汽车的自动驾驶。
也在做人形机器人。
所以现在想想大家就明白了。
因为自动驾驶上取得的每一次突破。
他几乎都可以
无缝的去迁移到机器人上。
也可以做那些什么工业自动化。
这些需求
他都是跟这个物理世界打交道的领域。
所以说我们其实现在见证的。
他不是一场交通工具的革命。
而是通用物理智能的一次革命。
所以小鹏这个公司。
我看到很多的一些。
就是资本房
就是资方
他们也是在对他的价值重新去重扣。
重新去评估
那么第二代的VLA。
当时发布之后
大家应该能看到
小鹏的股价
包括这个像摩根斯坦利。
美国银行恢复银行。
都是给他给出了一个叫买入的评级。
就这么多的大公司都给出了买入评级。
但是我在这里
我不推荐任何股票。
我只是说一个事实情况。
新闻里面都有报道的。
摩根斯坦利的研究报告当中就指出。
说小鹏第二代VLA的落地。
使其具备与特斯拉在全球市场。
直接竞争的能力
全球智能汽车产业的格局。
或迎来新的变量
但是我觉得这个浅了。
这不仅仅是汽车
包括居身智能
因为现在居身智能。
中国这股力量也非常的强。
所以你看
现在一台车已经是把我们从A点送到B点的铁皮盒子变成了一个。
可以跟你去沟通
可以帮你去思考
甚至比你更了解这个物理世界的推离引擎。
所以你说我们在讨论AI。
会不会取代我们工作的时候。
那么现在有一种新的。
能够理解
并且能够改造物理世界的智能。
它已经是融入到我们智商的生活里面了。
你现在换不换新的原车。
你换的新的原车带不带支架。
好
你带支架
那其实你就开始接触这个东西了吗？
那么这意味着什么？
其实没人能说得清。
但是这种感觉
你说像不像我们当年第一次看到iPhone。
我们也觉得旁边人用这个东西好傻呀？
上面连个键盘都没有。
但是也有人觉得很震撼。
从来没见过手机能是这种样子。
或者说有没有像我们第一次播号上网。
像我们80后还记得吗？
用那个猫播号
然后那个猫就会自自自在那边叫。
可能00后都不知道猫是什么东西。
通过电话线通过猫去上网。
去上BBS
对吧？
那种感觉特别的兴奋。
那么你知道世界将因此会改变。
对不对
只不过这一次改变。
可能不只是信息世界的改变。
而是我们身处的这个。
实实在在的物理世界的改变。
好吧？
那么以上就聊那么多。
这是本期节目缩的内容。
如果是喜马拉雅小宇宙的兄弟们。
也可能是姐妹们
大家如果听到这觉得还不错。
可以点一个订阅
没有订阅的点个订阅。
那么如果是喜马拉雅的听友呢？
你要是有免费的月票。
也帮忙投一投月票。
对于我的充牌名很有帮助。
那么隔壁小市牛刀的节目。
也可以听一听
挺有意思的
事就是事情的事
我会采访采访我身边的好朋友。
是个对谈节目
那么评论区每期我们会抽三位。
赠送由任严继提供的。
御录相离
试试装
一盒五个
非常的好吃
如果想买呢？
也可以上我的微信小程序。
就跟我的这个专辑的名字一样。
叫摆车权说
摆车权说你搜一下。
就能看到
好的
下面是关于上期节目的留言问答。
上一期节目
我们聊的是这个实体案件的回归。
然后我看到这个阿峰老师。
这一位听友他说
说到语音控制
我确实跟刀哥是同感。
并没有把我完全教育了。
我还是喜欢动手去操作。
而且你想一想
有的时候下班本身就很累了。
我上车是什么话都不想说。
你让我再去跟车机交流。
就显得好傻
我只想简单的动手操作。
打开空调打开音乐开车回家。
你说的太对了
特别是像你是做老师的。
我是做这种就自媒体的。
就出镜啊听连讲话呀？
我真的是我从一睁开眼睛。
我就在讲话
虽然说我喜欢讲
但是有的时候真的。
但我一个人都在车子里面。
我真的一个字一句话我都不想讲。
真的是这样子的
真的确实是
这个没办法
这种就是有人想说。
你为什么不用语音啊？
为什么不要
你不要问为什么？
你要涉身处地的在那个场景里面。
你去感受一下
人是一个情绪推动的动物。
人家讲说历史
如果按照理性推算的话。
那一百年后是什么样。
大家都知道
但是往往
它就不是按照这个方向去发展的。
很多的一些重大的历史的这种。
这种变革
或者历史的一些世界。
那就是
对吧？
冲关一路未红颜是吧？
就是伊斯格的这个获国殃民的妖技。
在这个大王的耳边。
在这个床边
就说了两边耳边风。
结果这个历史又变了。
历史根本就不能按照理性去推断的。
车也是一样的
车上这些功能也是一样的。
那具体
有人讲那三刀
那你说的东西客观吗？
哪有什么客观啊？
我做节目也只是
我想说什么？
我说什么？
对吧？
老听友都知道嘛？
粗质烂造胡说八道。
对吧？
那加一点干货
加点吹牛逼
那这个节目不就做出来了吗？
就是混嘛？
就混了个十来年嘛？
对不对
有人讲三刀你不专业。
我什么时候说过我专业。
我从来没说过我专业。
我就是知识的搬运工嘛？
像今天这些节目大家也听到了。
你不可能三刀
你具备这么多的知识的。
很多都是可能行业内的人。
也是第一次听说
或者说这个啊？
就三刀三刀说浅了。
或者就三刀是个外行。
无所谓
随地怎么讲
但是
我觉得这些节目说完之后。
我对于一些弄小白用户。
我说的是不是大白话。
对吧？
一听就懂吧？
你将来就是跟人吹牛皮。
或者说你去买
呃
带执行驾驶的车的时候。
你提到VLA
你今天能说出来了吧？
一代二代
第一阶段是什么？
第二阶段是什么？
有什么区别
清清楚楚明明了了。
如果你想看图文
你还能上我的公众号。
这个图文我们过几天也会发。
我现在所有的音频。
都会有文字吧？
我最近在布置我的这个。
呃
就是这个叫什么拍摄的场景。
还差窗帘跟桌子
妈窗帘桌子进来之后。
灯光不好了
我马上就把这些音频的节目。
我就放在我的这个工作史去录。
我就一边说一边拍视频。
我就把这种几十分钟的长视频。
我就给他放网上
你爱看不看
但是他有价值
所以我觉得到了像我们这种。
这种年龄
包括到了我们这种。
做自媒体的
已经十几年的算了。
算是这种老前辈了嘛？
你跟新人去拼什么创意什么东西。
没什么意义
我只能是寻求就是做自媒体。
我这种人
他存在的意义
他在这个生态位里面。
他还能留在那
对吧？
有的讲老连人你就别在那边混乱。
给年轻人腾腾位置了。
老连人还有经历呢？
中老连老灯还是有点经历的。
那有经历就要去审视一下自己。
你在这个生态位
你的价值是什么？
对吧？
你竟然不能像
你竟然不能像这个。
那些这种车评
有一些小姑娘啊？
或者小男生啊？
365天 350天在外面跑。
对不对
常年出差
拍各种车
我的天
你跟他们拼不了这个。
那我们就把内容做扎实。
对吧？
希望大家多多支持我。
评论是对我最大的支持。
点赞转发
是对我最大的支持。
你千万别动不动
导哥我听你节目听这么多年了。
我从来没留言
我每次看到这个留言。
我就心里面有点发酸。
你不留言
可能是有各种原因。
用车机在听
用手机可能在洗澡的时候听。
但是你每次留言
其实对我是一个支持。
我每次也会去看一看。
我留言区有多少个的。
评论留言
而且很多的甲方也会去看。
所以我还是希望大家多多留言。
真的多多支持我
多多交流
你喇叭就是发个
哎
这期节目不错
啊？
三道你
先撤下去啊？
多多支持你啊？
对吧？
正以月
正以皮肤啊？
都可以
这个评论量还是很重要的。
我们看下一位听友。
下一位听友叫做
RM Han Wang。
什么意思
他说空调风速
温度
前挡储物
这些功能啊？
其实最优解就是实体按键。
我作为自驾
租过几次理想L系列。
之后又买了理想I8的车主。
我也分享几个
我使用语音的这个感受。
第一个呢？
就是理想的语音唤醒啊？
你不一定要喊理想同学。
你可以直接说出自己的需求。
比如说空调调到二档。
打开前挡储物
那么理想同学他会回复。
好搞定
他说这个回答
就硬打磁啊？
他非常简单
他不会跟你去对话。
所以相对是比较省心的。
那么第二个呢？
就是理想汽车
对于语音的反应速度是比较快的。
可以说是秒急的
那么基本上不会说让我。
去花时间等待他去思考去响应。
而且呢？
他觉得I8呢？
还有一个进步的地方。
他以前租L系列的时候。
他感觉还是需要比较清晰。
相对大声的去说出需求。
但是在I8的车上。
几乎可以用接近耳语的音量。
就轻轻的说一下
他就能识别到
并且做出相应的反应。
这个我当时在I8上市的时候。
试驾的时候
他们的工程师也讲过这个这个原理。
是基于这个工程师。
他们家孩子在后排好几次唤醒不了。
然后那工程师就想到了。
要分区域去做这个识音。
而且要一定是靠近人声。
就是讲话
因为座椅是固定的嘛？
要靠近他这个嘴发声的这个位置。
继续识音
就是收他的声音嘛？
所以这个确实是很灵敏。
有一说一
他说我很小声的说。
打开座椅通风
空调调调二档
他都能有反应
那么第三一个呢？
就是有一个功能是我高频使用的。
而且是我认为语音。
是目前为止最方便的一个功能。
就是我经常需要在后排去换这个。
运动的衣服
有些人出去打球啊跑步啊？
这种他就需要在后排换衣服。
那么或者说我要去后背箱取东西。
那么我只要说一句。
打开全车的照明
那么车内的灯光就会全部亮起。
他说这个比那种用手。
去一个一个打开灯光。
要方便太多了
他说我以上是这个真实用车分享。
我绝对不是给理想的广告啊？
他还要解释一下
这个我完全的理解。
你比如说我每天出门。
我也会去开窗户去透风透气。
那么正常情况下就是要用手。
去一个一个的去按这个车窗控制键。
我现在已经不会这样操作了。
我都是
全车车窗打开20%。
或者全车车窗打开30%。
然后就滋前后左右四个车窗。
就同时下降20%。
或者30%
所以你想想看这是不是很方便啊？
你任何一个油车
如果不带这种智能座舱。
语音控制的
你都实现不了
你只能是一个一个的去开。
有的时候你开后排的车窗。
你你你一个手指没办好的话。
一键升降
你一下子就把后面的车窗全部建上去了。
你前面的车窗
你可能控制的舒服一点。
你后面的车窗是忙操作。
有的时候他开的比例是多少。
你又不能回头
你根本就不知道
是不是
但是只要一说
全车车窗打开20%。
哎
很方便
所以语音有语音的优势。
还是需要存在的
但是你要让他说长期培养这种。
语音唤醒的习惯
真的是很难啊？
那么第三位听友叫平森还能来二辆。
你看他酒量不错啊？
他说
确实实体按键比触屏好用太多了。
我家呢？
有一台国产的奥迪HL。
还有一台LC250。
如果静态看的话
奥迪A7的那两个屏幕。
那确实是比我的那个。
霸道LC250强得多的多了。
但是用起来的话
霸道的按键是又大又清晰。
每个按键都能出现在他该出现的位置。
用的特别的舒服
那么在反观A7
虽然说他的触控有震动反馈。
但是有延时啊？
而且冬天也不太灵敏。
那根本就没办法去忙操。
夏天手上又出汗
强迫症
下车他得把屏幕给擦一擦。
实在是感受差太多了。
没错
很多的越野车上的按键真的是非常的大。
霸道上面就是最典型的。
有的时候你想想看他为什么要按键大。
因为你在外面去越野的时候。
那车子左摇右晃左摇右晃的。
你别说不给个触屏了。
我觉得越野车型给触屏是最傻的。
因为你想想看在越野的环境里面。
那车子摇来晃摇来晃。
摇摇晃晃
这个时候你在屏幕上你要点。
你怎么点
你怎么点你就点不到。
你点不到你就生气。
对吧？
你生气怎么办
你把车卖掉
也不太可能
所以你看一下霸道上面。
每个按键那么大
像我这种手指又短又粗的。
我都能随便找一个按键。
我想用什么？
我甚至不用看
我忙操
我都知道在哪
的确是这样的
实体按键还是会适当的回归。
但是完全回归的可能性。
还是不大
好吧？
那么以上就是关于。
上期节目的留言互动。
感谢大家多多支持。
那么这期节目
也是希望我能够在评论区。
看到你的ID
好吧？
每期评论区我们抽三位。
会赠送由认严计
提供的预录相离
试试装一盒五个
想买的话也可以上我的小程序。
摆车全说
我的商城里面进行购买。
好
那么以上就是今天。
节目的所有的内容。
给大家收听
那么想关注我的更多内容。
可以上Bilibili。
也是我们专辑的同名。
叫摆车全说这个账号。
还有就是我的短视频。
三刀砍车
单人旁砍达山的砍。
在抖音
小红书视频号快手上都有。
还有我的个人微博。
摆车全说三刀
那么如果想进我们的社群的话。
也可以关注订阅号。
摆车全说
现在每天都有原创文章的更新。
那么或者加微信
4641 5254。
想跟我一对一的交流。
也加这个微信
那么今天这期就到这里。
我们下期接着聊
拜拜